welcome back to cbs mornings we have an
update on yesterday's story about a bill
to expand benefits for millions of
injured veterans that was held up by
senate republicans supporters cheered
last night as the senate approved the
pact act making it easier for vets to
get treatment if they were exposed to
toxic burn pits scott mcfarlane was
there for the vote and the celebration
tears of joy outside the capitol for
veterans and their families some of whom
spent days and nights camped outside
along with advocate and former tv host
jon stewart to pressure senators to
break through their stalemate you think
your group moved the senators
i'll tell you they sure did senators
approved long-awaited legislation to
expand medical benefits for potentially
millions of service members exposed to
burn pits in iraq and afghanistan and
other toxins as far back as vietnam
veterans groups say they were blindsided
last week when some republicans blocked
passage of the law in a procedural
dispute over how to budget money for the
tens of billions of dollars in costs the
motion is agreed to a dispute senators
resolved last night finally
at long last
america lived up to its ideals
by saying to our veterans who have been
exposed to toxic chemicals from burn
pits
we have your back among those attending
the vote susan zaire whose son-in-law
heath robinson died of lung cancer after
returning from iraq what was heath's
experience like the first words out of
the oncologist's mouth when he was
giving the diagnosis was
what the hell have you been exposed to
president biden celebrated the bill's
passage from the white house zaire says
she expects to attend when mr biden
signs the bill into law
which he says he'll do when it reaches
his desk for cbs mornings i'm scott
mcfarland in washington d.c
when talking to jon stewart yesterday i
said how are you doing he said i'm
exhausted
sad tired but we have to push on and i
know he was speaking for all of those
veterans and their families that were
going through this for years he was
doing that he's been advocating for this
for 15 years and the fact though that it
takes someone with his platform
to get something done into lawmakers
exactly is sort of troubling that it
should not be just this one person all
americans could get behind something
like this but the fact that he's shown a
spotlight on it for so many years is
what pushed it over the finish line